DAVE SMITH: My
name is Dave Smith.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google,
working on IoT platforms.
And today, I'd like to spend
a little bit of time talking
to you about how
you can build Cloud
services for smart
devices, and how
you can integrate those services
with the Google Assistant.
We're going to walk through some
components of an example Cloud
service solution, and then
we'll discuss a little bit
of how you can connect
a service like that
to the Assistant for smart
home device interactions.
All right, so let's get started.
So voice assistants have
accelerated adoption
of smart devices in the home.
They've become the
common thread that
enables different manufacturers
to work seamlessly
together inside of one space.
The Smart Home API
enables developers
to integrate their
Cloud-connected devices
with the Google Assistant, and
leverage the natural language
processing that's built into
the Assistant for processing
queries and commands for those
devices that are in the home.
Smart Home is part
of Actions on Google,
which is the wider
platform designed
to enable conversational
engagements with users
through assistant-enabled
devices.
However, Smart Home uses a more
simplified model of interaction
that abstracts away some of
the conversational pieces
of a typical voice action.
Just out of curiosity,
how many of you
have developed using the
Actions on Google Cloud
Platform before?
OK, so for those
of you who have,
you're familiar with some of
the conversational interactions
that typically take place
when building an action.
And using Smart Home, you're
going to see that some of that
is simplified quite a bit.
Developers don't
really have to interact
with the request and response
model of talking to the user.
We focus more on the devices.
So with Smart Home
integrations, we
focused on creating a clear
and structured interface
for devices.
Devices are broken into
device types and traits, which
provide a well-understood schema
for reporting those device
capabilities to Google.
You can see an example of
two of those device types
here on the slide, the light
device and a thermostat device,
and we have many others as well.
Within these individual
device types,
these encapsulate
a series of, what
we call traits that define
what the capabilities are
of that device.
So, for example, with
the light, that device
can be turned on and off.
You can adjust the brightness
or you can, in some cases,
maybe, modify the color setting.
Whereas for a thermostat,
you have the capability
of modifying what we call
the temperature setting.
And then within each
individual trait,
these are further
subdivided to provide
individual attributes
that describe the state
of that particular device.
So, for example,
with a thermostat,
the temperature
setting trait defines
three attributes for that
thermostat-- mode, like heat
or cool or off or auto, things
like that, the temperature set
point, as well as the
ambient temperature.
So we put all these
things together
to define what we call
the device schema,
to provide known device types
interactions with the Google
Assistant.
Now, having such a
well-defined schema
enables the Assistant to bring
highly intelligent interactions
about how they process
queries and commands,
because it now has a strong
understanding of what
those devices are and
what those devices can do.
In other words,
with Smart Home, we
allow Google to handle
the conversation
so that the developers
can focus on the devices.
The Google Assistant also
adds contextual understanding
to your devices
through the Home Graph.
Home Graph is our
technology that
understands the relationships
between structures, rooms,
users, and devices.
The Home Graph is what
powers our ability
to understand user queries
in context of the environment
and be able to translate that
back to individual devices.
It enables us to
say things like,
turn on the upstairs lights, or
what's the temperature in here,
by providing that relative
context between the user
and the devices around them.
All right, quick show of hands.
How many of you in here own
an Assistant-enabled device
in your home, whether that's
a Smart Speaker like a Google
Home or a Smart Display like a
Home Hub that I have up here?
OK, good.
Now for those of you who raised
your hands, how many of you
have at least one smart device
in your home that is connected
to that Assistant device?
OK, good, good, so about
half, maybe a little bit less.
So what I'd like to do here
is I want to quickly show you
a demo so that everybody's
on the same page of what
this actually looks
like in practice.
So up here, I have
a Google Home Hub
and I have a Nest
thermostat, and I'm just
going to walk through some
very simple interactions of how
we can interact, as a
user, with the Assistant,
with one of these smart devices.
So let's quickly
switch to the demo.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
The mic's back on.
DAVE SMITH: All right, so
wake up my devices here.
All right, so as a user, I've
installed both of these devices
in my home and I use
the Google Assistant
to set these devices up, add
them to rooms in my home,
and do all these pieces
associated with the Home Graph
that I just described.
And what that enables
me to do as a user is
walk up to my device and
say simple queries like, hey
Google, what's the
temperature on stage?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: It's
currently 71 degrees.
DAVE SMITH: So this is the
Smart Home API in action, right?
Basically what's
happening is Google
is connecting to the
partner's Cloud service,
in this case Nest,
and it's asking
for the current state of
that particular device
and then reporting
that back to the user.
Notice, also, that I'm referring
to that device by its location,
in this case, on stage.
And this is because
the Assistant
has assigned that device to the
room using the Home Graph, when
I initially set it up.
Now because the Home Graph
knows that this display
and that thermostat are
both in the same room,
I can also make more relative
queries like, hey Google,
what's the temperature in here?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: It's
currently 71 degrees.
DAVE SMITH: We get the
same result, right?
Similarly, we can send
commands to these devices
to make a change.
Hey Google, set the
temperature to 65 degrees.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK, setting
the stage to 65 degrees.
DAVE SMITH: And we can see
the adjustment also made
on the thermostat as well.
So this is, again, using
that Smart Home API.
But in this case, Google
is sending a command
to that partner cloud
integration to say,
you need to adjust the state
of this particular device.
And in this case, it's
providing a new set point, OK?
Now even here, we can use
Google's natural language
understanding to make
more natural queries
at the same time.
Hey, Google, make
it a little warmer.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: You got it.
Warming up the stage.
DAVE SMITH: OK.
Now, the other nice thing
about integrating your devices
with the Google
Assistant is not only
do you get this
voice interaction,
but on Assistant surfaces
that have UI, like this Smart
Display, or an Android
phone, or an IOS device,
you can also interact
using the touch UI.
So, for example, you saw
it for just a moment,
but I'll bring it
back up quickly.
I can look at the view of
that device on this display
and I can interact
with it directly
to make that change
on the device as well.
Now, all of this
functionality is
built into the Google Home app,
into Google Assistant devices.
And all you have to provide
is the interaction of how
to ask your devices
for information
and how to manipulate
them through commands.
And we're going to
talk a little bit more
about how all that stuff works.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: The mic's off.
DAVE SMITH: All right.
So there's two things that I
want to go over with you here
today.
And the first that
we want to discuss
is, let's talk a
little bit about,
how do we actually build
a Cloud service that
communicates with devices?
So, quickly, just kind of
showing you a diagram, this
is essentially what you
just saw in the demo, right?
The user can interact with
an Assistant-enabled device,
and that assistive device
will interact with your Cloud
service in order to communicate
with that particular device.
So the Smart Home interaction
is a cloud-to-cloud integration,
which means, as a
device manufacturer,
you have to provide your
own cloud service for users
to register and
manage their devices.
And then the Smart
Home actions platform
can integrate with
that cloud service
using a series of web
hooks to control and access
those devices.
We'll talk more about
that in a little bit.
Now, depending on where you are
in your development process,
you may already have
this functionality
in place for your
devices, but I want
to explore a little bit of
what an example might look
like if you were to build this
device cloud service on Google
Cloud.
So this is an example
architecture using services
from the Google Cloud Platform,
as well as from Firebase,
that we use to fulfill the
requirements for the Smart Home
use case.
Now the sample code for what I'm
going to show you is on GitHub,
so I recommend that you take
a look at that after the talk.
It's an end to end sample that
includes the Cloud service
as well as client applications
for mobile and web,
interactions with sample
devices, all that stuff.
So in the sample
architecture, we
have Cloud IoT Core, which
enables secure device
connectivity over
and MGTT or HTDP.
We're also using Firebase, which
enables easy client application
development for mobile and
web through their series
of native investee case.
We also get access to
Firebase authentication,
which adds the
ability to provide
user identity and access
control over all of this data.
Now, in this example, devices
report their current state
through IoT Core, which then
bridges that data into Pub/Sub
and through to Cloud Firestore.
Using Firebase
authentication in Firestore,
we can build client applications
that expose that data directly
to users for device management.
And then users now
have the ability
to control their
devices, and they do that
by updating the
data in Firestore,
which then triggers
commands back to the devices
through IoT Core.
Now, this means that,
in this architecture,
Firestore becomes the
primary source of truth
for all of your device data.
And that's going to become
really important when
we start talking more
about Smart Home,
so I'll come back to that
a little bit later on.
But just keep in mind for
now that Cloud Firestore
is that central point
where all of the data
is accessible for
all of the devices.
OK, so why Cloud IoT Core?
IoT Core enables
secure connections
to Google Cloud for resource
constrained devices, OK.
Think small, tiny, $1
microcontroller, less than $1
type devices, right?
Generally speaking, if
you're building something
like a smart light,
you're not going
to want to put a quad
core processor in there
running embedded Linux, I hope.
Instead, you typically
want low power devices
that have very low footprint,
and all of those things.
So we use Cloud
IoT Core to enable
those devices to connect
directly to Google Cloud,
and that's done two ways.
The first is using MQTT, which
is a low overhead protocol that
is ideally suited for IoT
devices or low bandwidth
devices.
We do also support HTDP, but
generally speaking, most users
of IoT Core are using the
MQTT protocol, primarily
for this reason.
The other, and probably
more important reason,
is for authentication.
So we need to make sure
that these devices have
a secure connection
to Google Cloud.
And as I mentioned before,
generally speaking we
try to get the smallest, lowest
footprint, cheapest device we
can into these Smart
Home devices, whatever
we need to supply the use case.
This often introduces
constraints on both CPU
as well as memory,
primarily memory, right.
The cheaper the device,
the less onboard memory
it's going to have.
In addition to this, IoT
solutions really, to be secure,
need a mutual
authentication solution.
It's not enough for
the device to be
able to trust the server
that it's connecting to.
It's just as important
for the server
to be able to trust the
devices that are connecting
to it in an IoT situation, OK.
So we need to have mutual
authentication going
between these two pieces.
Generally speaking, you
would solve that problem
with something like a mutual
TLS stack on your device
or on your client.
However, typical
mutual TLS stacks
require way too much memory
for a microcontroller
in a lot of cases, whether it's
the stack itself or the fact
that the client is also
responsible for housing
the full certificate
chain that it
has to supply up to the server.
All of that stuff can blow out
the memory of a microcontroller
very, very quickly.
So Cloud IoT Core is designed
to solve this problem
by creating an asymmetric
authentication between the two.
It still uses TLS 1.2 to
authenticate the server
to the devices.
So IoT Core still
presents certificates
that can be validated on the
device, and all of that stuff.
But the devices authenticate
themselves back to IoT Core
using a much simpler
public-private key
authentication mechanism,
using JSON Web Tokens or jots.
Basically what happens here
is, when an IoT Core device is
connecting to the
service, it signs a jot
with a private key that is
stored privately and securely
on that device, and
then provides that jot
as the password for
the connection to IoT
Core over MQTT or HTDP.
The public key is shared
at provisioning time
with IoT Core.
So it can use that
public key to validate
that the information coming
in from this device is valid,
it is the device ID that
it's claiming to be,
and all of those things.
So we still have a secure
authentication mechanism
from the client device
back up to the server,
but it's using a much more
lightweight process that
is more easy to fit into these
constrained embedded devices
than a full-blown mutual TLS.
All right, one of the
advantages of using
Firebase authentication for
user identity and access control
is security rules.
Has anyone developed
using Firebase in here?
OK, just a few people.
Firebase is an amazing platform.
It is built on
Google Cloud, but it
adds a bunch of additional
developer services that
make it really, really
integrated, seamless,
and easy to use.
And one of those is Firebase
authentication integration
with Data Store using
the security rules.
So with security rules,
we can seamlessly
integrate user permissions
to access the Firestore data,
using a very simple
declarative rule syntax,
without having to
write any code, right.
And this syntax
allows us to validate,
based on the authenticated
users and the information
that we have about them, what
types of data in the database
should they be able
to access, right.
And this is basically a
snapshot of the Firestore rules
from the [INAUDIBLE]
example that we have,
which allow us to control that
only authenticated users should
be able to access device
data, and they should only
be able to access
the devices where
we have marked them as the
owner of that device, OK.
Now, the logistics of
how all that happens
is, you can look
in the sample code.
But the basic idea is, with just
a couple of lines in the rules,
we apply that over our
entire database, OK.
So it's very simple, it's very
seamless, it's easy to do.
We can also restrict not only
user access, but users' ability
to do things like create
new devices, right,
so that we can mediate the
process of device registration.
And we'll talk about that a
little bit more in a minute.
OK, along with
security rules, one
of the other primary
advantages of Firebase
is the ability to build client
apps, as I mentioned before.
So this is a screenshot of the
mobile app that comes along
with the end-to-end example.
This happens to have
been written in Flutter
using the native Flutter SDK
that's available for Firebase.
Firebase also has SDKs
for Android and iOS.
And on the web, we have
SDKs for React, Angular,
and many, many more, right.
So it's a very easy
system to integrate
for front-end applications
both on the web and on mobile.
And this enables you
to very quickly create
properly functional
applications to enable
users to authenticate,
access their devices,
manage them, control, all
of those types of things.
Now, the mobile
application in particular
is actually quite
important because it's
part of a critical path
for device provisioning.
It allows users to activate
and register their devices.
So I won't ask for a
show of hands this time,
but I'll bet that those of you
who mentioned that you have
activated a smart device
in your home before,
more than likely you had
to download the mobile app
from that manufacturer
to provision
that device, whether
it was on your network,
or with your account,
or any of that.
This is a very common
pattern because it's a device
that we can pretty much
assume that all users will
have with them, right?
Some devices can
do this on the web.
Most of them use the mobile app.
So let's dive a bit deeper into
the device provisioning process
and how we might do this with
something like Cloud IoT Core.
So, within IoT Core, I
mentioned before that devices
use this public-private key
authentication mechanism when
they connect to the service.
So one of the things that
the OEM, or the factory,
is responsible for doing
is producing that key pair
and ensuring that the public
key is shared with IoT Core
and the private key is
securely stored on that device
before it's boxed up
and ready to ship.
That basically creates the
initial device association
to say that this
is a valid device,
this is its ID,
or serial number,
or whatever you want to provide.
That can be done by
the manufacturer.
But then, at some point later,
when the user actually takes
this thing out of the box, we
have to have a way for them
to prove that the device
they have in front of them,
that they're trying to register,
is a valid device that we
know about.
One of the ways that
you can do that is you
can share that same
public key with the user
so that they can provide
that public key during device
registration and allow
us, on the back end,
to validate that the
public key matches
the one that's in IoT Core for
that particular device ID, OK?
There's a number
of ways you could
do that, in terms of how
that information is shared.
One example, which is how
we do it in the example code
that I mentioned
to you earlier, is
you can bind that public
key to something physical
on the device, like a QR code.
And this is a very common
provisioning method
that's used by a lot
of Smart Home vendors.
One of the nice features
of this functionality
is that it actually enhances the
security of the device as well,
over doing provisioning methods
wirelessly like BLE or MDNS,
or some of those others.
Not that there's anything
wrong with those,
but they require additional
layers of security
to make sure you can prove that
that device is the one you're
talking to, right?
When you physically bind
this data to the device,
you can guarantee
that the user has
to have physical access to the
device in order to register it.
So you can bind all of
that data-- maybe you
want some additional metadata
like the device serial
number or anything else-- but
the public key in this example
is the one that's
most important.
You can encode all of that
onto the device using something
like a QR code.
And then, because all of our
mobile devices have cameras,
you can use the
mobile application
to scan that QR code, gather
that information easily--
not asking the
user to type it in
or anything like that--
they just scan the QR code,
submit that device
information up to Firestore,
and then our back
end service can then
validate that information.
So the user basically
submits a request
to register this device
with a particular device
ID and public key.
And then in the back end, we
can validate with IoT Core,
oh yes, that device ID does
exist, here's its public key.
And that actually matches what
the user has just given you.
OK, so we know, to a
reasonable degree of certainty,
that the user actually has
the device in front of them
that they're trying to register.
And then from there, we can
create the actual device node,
assign that user
ID as the owner,
and then the user can see it
in their mobile app on the web,
and all of that.
OK, so that's kind of a quick
overview of the example code.
I encourage you to take
a look at the code.
We also have a couple
of blog posts out
on that that are linked
from the repository,
as well, to kind of
give you some more
detail on the nitty gritty of
how all that was put together.
So let's shift gears
a little bit, now
and talk a little
bit more about,
now that we have a
Cloud Service built,
what does it mean to
actually integrate
that service with
the Google Assistant?
How do we get the interactions
that I just showed you before,
with a Smart Display or a Smart
Speaker or devices like that?
So this diagram kind
of outlines the basics
of how the Google
Assistant expects
to interact with
your Cloud service
when you're integrating
the smart home API.
Integrating with
Smart Home basically
requires you, as a developer,
to implement the pieces
up here that are in
yellow, which boils down
to two primary elements.
The first is account
linking, which
is represented by
that web sign in flow
that you see up
there at the top.
And the second is
intent fulfillment,
which you see between
the cloud services
there in the Assistant.
So we're going to talk about
both of these in a little bit
more detail, here, starting
with the account linking.
So account linking is
a process initiated
from within the Google Home app
that enables users to authorize
access to those devices.
So some of you have
probably experienced this
before, but to just kind
of talk through the idea--
if a user wants to
enable their Smart Home
device through the Assistant,
they go through the Google Home
app, they decide they
want to add a new device,
and they click that they want
to link their existing account
from some other vendor
like Nest, or whoever,
to the Google Assistant.
That triggers a sign in flow
through this account linking
that enables them to log in
using the account that they had
with that partner device, and
then authorize that the Google
Assistant can have access to all
of the devices that are managed
by that particular account.
What you're seeing here
is just a screenshot
of the account
linking implementation
that we have provided.
And again, that end-to-end
example, that's on GitHub.
So Smart Home account
linking really boils
down to three primary elements.
Now, for those of you who
are familiar with OAuth 2.0,
this is going to
look very familiar.
Because basically what we
require of your service
is to be able to expose to us an
OAuth 2.0 compatible endpoint,
so that we can do an
authorization code
flow with your cloud service.
OK, so that basically
means we need
to be able to handle the
authorization step, which
is the user signing in and
granting access, and then
later on in the process
providing access credentials
and refreshed credentials,
which again is a typical OAuth
flow for those things.
So in the example, if
you were to go and look
through the example
code on GitHub,
we've implemented this
in the following way.
So the authorization
step, we interact
with Firebase
authentication, which
is really nice because
it means we don't have
to write much code to do this.
Firebase authentication handles
this part of the authorization
flow very well.
The user can sign in
using the same account,
and then we can use that
user's ID token, provided to us
by Firebase, as the
authorization code
that we can provide
back to Google, OK.
Very little code
involved in this part.
Then, later, Google will pass
that authorization code back
to our Cloud service,
asking us for what's
known as a refresh token.
This is basically
a persistent token
that should be valid as long
as the user's account is
linked to the Assistant, OK.
So this is something
that we, on our side,
need to generate,
return, and then
we persist it in Firestore.
Now, in the example, if you look
through the source code, what
you'll see is that we
actually use the same jot
standard to create the
tokens for this purpose
that IoT Core uses to
authenticate devices.
It's the same standard, in case
you're looking at the code.
Once we've created
this refresh token,
we can then return that back.
This is a token
that now authorizes
Google to periodically
request access credentials
from our service,
known as access tokens.
So this refresh token will be
passed back to your service
during and after the account
linking process, periodically,
to get what's known
as an access token.
Access tokens are short lived.
They expire at some time
in the future, which
is why this process
happens periodically so
that, when that
token expires, you
can give Google a new one,
and so on and so forth.
So similarly, when we
get this refresh token,
it's our responsibility
to validate
that the token we received
matches the one we persisted
for this particular user.
If it's not, it's
an invalid token.
And then, if that
does match, then we
can provide an access token.
And then, later on, that will
be used in future requests
for intent fulfillment-- that
we'll talk about in a minute--
for accessing actual
device data, OK.
The last piece to account
linking is at some point,
the user may decide to
unlink their account
from the Assistant.
When that happens, you'll
receive a disconnect message
and your Cloud service
basically, in our example,
just needs to destroy the
token that we considered valid,
as a refresh.
There are a number of different
ways to implement this.
And in a lot of
cases you can even
use third party services that
support OAuth, like Auth Zero,
or maybe you've already got
this in your application.
But this kind of
gives you an idea
of how we built it
in the example code,
in case you want to see
what this might look like,
implementing it for yourself.
All right, let's move a little
bit now to intent fulfillment.
So Smart Home Intents enable
users to access and control
the devices that they've linked
through voice interaction,
as well as through the
Google Home UI, Remember,
I kind of showed
you both of those
as we were going
through the demo.
Smart Home Intents,
the fulfillment
basically requires that you
handle three primary intents,
a sync intent, a query
intent, and an execute intent.
So the sync intent basically
provides information
to the Assistant about what
devices does this user control.
The query intent allows you
to return the current state
of a particular device.
And the execute
intent is what you'll
use to modify the state
of a particular device.
OK, so let's look at these
in a little bit more detail.
Here we go.
So the sync intent
is sent automatically
after account
linking is complete.
So this is the
Assistant's attempt
to ask your Cloud
service, what are
all the devices that this
authenticated user controls,
and what can those devices do?
So your job is
basically to respond
to this intent by providing
the metadata about all
of the device types and the
device traits associated
with the devices under
that user's account.
So in this example, we might
return a response that says,
this user has four light
devices in their account.
All four of them can
report the on-off trait,
but only two of them
support brightness, right,
something along those lines.
So this is the kind of metadata
that you provide in response
to a sink.
Now generally
speaking, syncs are not
performed on a regular basis.
By default, a sync
is only performed
when the account is linked, OK.
And this can be problematic
if this is the only thing
that your service
implements because it means
that if the user
adds a new device,
they have to actually
unlink their account
and relink it again
to see the new device.
Now we mitigate
this by enabling you
to call a method
through the Home Graph
API called request sync.
So if, inside of
your application,
users add new devices or
remove devices, or maybe just
the devices that are
there change capabilities
in some way, you can
use the Home Graph
API to tell the assistant
to request a new sync.
Something has changed.
We need you to
send a sync again.
And when that happens, you'll
get the same sync intent
so that you can respond
with the new set of data,
the new set of devices
and capabilities,
associated with that
particular user.
So request sync
is very important
because it enables users to
have a seamless experience
between the Google Assistant
and your application,
and not forcing them to manually
resync or relink their account
or anything like that
just because they
bought a new device,
right, and applied it
to an existing account.
All right, so the query intent.
Query is responsible
for reporting
the current state of
an individual device
or a set of devices.
In this case, the
Assistant is asking you
for some more specific
information about, what
is this device currently doing?
Is the light currently on?
Is the thermostat set to 20
degrees or 25 degrees, right?
So in this case,
your response is
going to provide back the actual
values for all of the device
traits and attributes,
that you provided,
that this device was able to
report inside of the sync.
This includes whether or not
the device is online or offline,
if you're tracking
that kind of status.
The query intent is
typically triggered
when the user navigates
to a particular device
from the Google Home app.
Or maybe through voice when
they say something like, what
is the temperature in here?
As soon as that
request is triggered,
then this intent is going to
be sent to your Cloud service,
and you need to send that
back with the result.
Now, both the sync intent
and the query intent,
in the end-to-end example
that we've been discussing,
both of those only have
to go so far as Firebase.
Because in the architecture,
that we've created
Firestore is the source of
truth for all of this data.
So I can get all the information
I need about what devices
a user owns, what
they can do, and what
the current state
of those devices
is, simply by
talking to Firebase.
I don't have to
actually go all the way
and do a round trip
to the devices, which
is very important
because it enables
those queries coming back from
voice to be instantaneous.
You're not seeing
this long latency
while we actually block waiting
for something to go all the way
down to the device and back.
So this enables a much
quicker interaction
with the Google Assistant.
The execute intent
enables you to modify
the state of your
particular devices
based on a user command.
So this basically
comes in and describes
a set of traits that
should be updated
for a given device or
a given set of devices.
And these can be
provided in a group.
So you can get an
execute intent that
says you should modify on-off
and brightness for these three
lights, and then you do all
of that in a single set.
That basically is
what allows us to be
able to make some of
those more complex queries
like, turn on the
lights upstairs.
There could be six lights
from three different vendors
in that particular
group, and this
enables us to make
sure that that all
happens in a single command.
The response from
an execute intent
is a little bit different
because we're not actually
telling the Assistant any more
information about the devices.
We just need to
tell the Assistant
whether that succeeded or not.
So you can tell it
for any particular one
of those devices, did
the command succeed?
And succeed really
means that you
know it got down to the device,
the device made that change,
and reported that it was
successful back to you.
So this is a case where
you might actually
be talking to Cloud
IoT Core directly,
depending on your application.
In the sample, we
don't actually do that.
We modify the state of these
devices through Firestore.
And because of that, the
responses back from the device,
that a change has actually
happened, is asynchronous.
So in our example, we actually
return a different state
than success, which is pending.
Pending tells the
Assistant that, yes,
a command is
expected to succeed,
but we haven't seen it yet.
You can also tell the Assistant
if you know, for some reason,
that that command failed
because of an error,
or maybe because the
device isn't reachable
because it's not online.
So all that information
can be reported back
as a result of an execute intent
for each individual device.
And then as you might expect,
this is the type of intent
that your cloud service will
see when the user walks up
to this device and says
something like, set
the temperature to 52 degrees.
That's going to be packaged
up as an execute intent
and then sent down to
your Cloud service.
OK, now one additional
piece of information here
that's relatively
important to implement--
it's not required per se,
but provides a much better
experience similar
to request sync--
is there's another API
call through the Home Graph
that we call report state.
If the device changes state
locally, for some reason,
maybe it's a light switch
and they actually walked over
and flipped on the switch--
I know it's weird to think of,
but it actually does happen--
or maybe they changed that
state outside of the Assistant,
right.
Maybe in your client
application or through the web
they modified the
state of that device.
This is something
where that state
change isn't known automatically
by the Google Assistant.
And by default, this
is not a huge problem,
because whenever the user
wants to ask something,
you'll generally
initiate a query anyway.
But queries have
latency to them.
So what you can do to improve
this experience is implementing
the report state API where, any
time one of those local state
changes happens,
that you're aware of,
you can report that state
change to the Assistant
by providing the exact
traits and values that
changed for any given device.
This can drastically reduce
the number of query intents
that your service sees, because
if there are recent state
changes on a device, Google
Assistant can actually
look those up locally without
having to ask you again.
In addition, in cases
where, like in our example
that I mentioned before, where
state changes in response
to commands might
be asynchronous.
So you can't actually
tell, in response
to an execute, whether
the command succeeded
and so you return
pending instead.
Report state is the way
that you can basically
tell the Assistant, OK, that
command has actually changed.
Because it happened in
an asynchronous way,
you can call this API, this is
the new state of the device.
So report state
is really helpful
for confirming those
successive pending commands
and in reducing the latency
between those potential queries
by notifying the Assistant of
those changes as they happen.
OK, that's pretty much it.
So, just to quickly
summarize, we
talked about Cloud
IoT Core as a way
to securely connect constrained
devices to Google Cloud.
We added Firebase as
a way to easily build
those authenticated client
apps to give users access
to those devices.
And then we included the
Google Assistant as a way
to provide intelligent
interactions
with those smart home devices.
[MUSIC PLAYING]